this is a presentation on extending the
mysql shell
with javascript
this is a presentation for openjs world
2021
my name is dave stokes i have the honor
of being a mysql community manager for
oracle corporation
i've been on the mysql community team
for just over a decade before that one
of my jobs
was the head of the certification
department
and i'm going to
show you how to extend the new shell
that we have
with javascript
let me turn off the webcam to save some
screen space
mysql sh which is our new shell if
you've used our old shell in the past it
was very much an old style command line
interface
the new shell is a brand new product
that came out three years ago with the
launch of mysql8 and has a lot of very
interesting features
the main use for it
is to process
code written in either javascript
python
and sql
and you'll see that does all those very
well now any of the executed code is
processed in any of these languages so
you can write something in python have
it run in nsql or javascript and run
python or however
it's all basically
based on the current language that
you're currently active with
well how do you tell that
well
here's where i fired up mysqlh
and
you'll see the prompt there in yellow
the js for
javascript that's why i'm here open
java.js21
now if you want to uh work directly with
python
you type in slash py
and if you're a old
database person like myself and want to
use structured query language
slash sql
by the way something to point out
rather than our own monochromatic shell
we now have colors and the command line
prompt is all customizable
in this case here i typed in a backslash
s to get the status and you'll see that
i'm in sql mode
and if you look a little bit deeper
you'll notice that we are using ssl
we're using tls aes 256 encryption by
default when you set up your mysql
server that is enabled for you
we wanted to have mysql 80b secure out
of the box
now if you want to turn that off because
your environment where everything is air
gapped from the outside world or you
have some other way of securing stuff
you can turn it off by default we turn
it on
by the way if you notice at the bottom
of the screen the second lineup
we can compress your data as it goes
back and forth between the server and
your client here the mysql shell
also i'd like to point out with mysql8
uh the default character set
for the server
and the client is utf-8mb4
a big part of that is because
of the json support that we have json by
default is all utf-84
also it lets you use emojis wherever you
want
so let's carry on
now with the new shell there are two
types of sessions that you can have
we have the classic session which is
what you probably are used to from my
school five seven all back to the three
two one days
which listens on port 3306
also four years ago or three years ago
when my mysql8 came out we had the x
protocol which we call the xdev api
which speaks both structured query
language and nosql
by default it listens on port 33060
and this is a nice little diagram that
shows kind of our worldview we're at the
top level you have applications talking
through connectors
or you can use scripts right running
through the mysql shell
and they can talk the standard protocol
or the x protocol
and on the server you can have
relational tables and you can have no
sql json document stores
and you can use them interchangeably so
in the nosql site i can actually reach
relational tables
and the relational table side i can
actually go out and get information from
json document collections
now
you can use the functions that are
available
in javascript and python mode to create
multiple sessions with multiple objects
doing all sorts of different stuff
these session objects lets you
run concurrent
sessions you can interact with each
other uh or you have different things
going at different times so you have a
long running report in one and some
quick and dirty stuff running another
uh all from one instance of the mysql
shell
now default when you log in uh you fire
mysql sh
and the underlined here in red we have
backslash c
and then the account and the host name
and
in this example here the password has
been cached
and saved
and it creates a session to rooted
localhost
and in this case it's going to run on
the new x protocol
and it's ready to go and you see down
here that works on the bottom line here
that mysql is running on the local host
listing on port 33060
ssl is enabled and we're in javascript
mode
well if you want
multiple sessions what you can do is
what you see here you fire mysql shell
you set up a variable variable session
one
equals mysql dot get classic session
that's the port 3306
give the parameters to log in and
suddenly we have session one if i want
to set up multiple sessions i can have
bar session two of our session x
and uh
address them by the session.one object
by the way if you want encryption as i
said earlier it's turned on by default
let's say you're an environment where
you don't have it turned on by default
you can still enable it all you have to
do is when you create your session
specify the mysql x protocol
and give all the parameters host
root password and then the path to the
various files for encryption
compression is very much the same way
you can
you can say that it's required
what algorithms you want to use and the
level of compression
by the way as mentioned earlier
the first time you log in using the
mysql shell
it will ask you for that account if you
want to save the password
it gives you the options of yes no never
and the default is no
this is stored in a
hash
uh not human readable
and uh becomes very handy for those who
don't like typing passwords
also you need to buy skill shell from
the command line so if you have a
javascript program that you want to feed
into mysql shell it has all the
authentication
parameters set in there all you have to
do is type in mysql shell
and
use the less than sign
from your javascript
file and away it goes
now by default your
your
your files that you're going to write
for your
the server if you don't if you want to
share with other folks this are going to
be star stored under user share
mysql sh modules
and you can have javascript and python
modules in this example here a quick
little one
called dave.js
has two little quick functions
uh you can also
change your path so if you have your
uh something off your your root
directory uh you can specify that there
too
by the way if you want to use the xdev
api for using mysql it's a nosql json
document store
this is an example written in javascript
we create a variable called my session
which says we're going to connect with
the x protocol with the username
password and machine
name
and then from there we're going to go
out and get the schema now in the mysql
world we use schema and database
interchangeably
that's just the way we've been doing it
and that's how we're gonna do it so
we're saying for our session we're gonna
go out get the world underscore x
database or schema and in that database
there's a document collection of json
documents called country info we're
gonna go out there and find everything
in that collection then we're going to
execute that
and from there we do a fetch one to read
all the records
now if you notice this is going out and
pulling back data not using sql
very
javascript like very modern design like
you're not finding sql syntax so if you
love databases but hate sql syntax this
is another option for you
by the way when you run this the script
and you get the proper information
it goes out i believe it returns 237
different documents with the very
various information
now the rolex
schema and the world schema are two
schemas that we have out on the
mysql.com website that we use for
documentation and illustrative purposes
such as documentation examples
and that's free to download if you want
to play with it
also if you're in javascript mode and
you decide that you just have to run an
sql query but i want to change modes all
i have to do is say okay for this
session
the current session i'm on i want to run
an sql command break cleverly cult run
sql function and then just plug in your
structured query language
and in this example we're going out to
the mysql schema
and getting the user table and getting a
list of users and they're the machines
they're allowed from
very very happy
so you don't like this normal output you
can get
as an option from the horizontal output
either json or vertical all i have to do
is
shell.options.set result format json
and then when you run the same command
this time you just limited it to
you get the same information in a json
format
now if you want to make all your output
forever and ever json uh you change this
set to a set capital p persist
and that would save that out there for
you
by the way as i mentioned you don't have
to use structured query language this is
an example where say we don't know what
our data is going to look like we want
to use a database but we don't have time
to set up the structures the
relationships all the tables the indexes
and all that
what we can do is
create a schema in this case it's called
demo and then within that schema we'll
create a document collection in this
case we're going to cleverly call it
openjs like the show you're talking at
and then we say db and db is an object
that points to the current schema
open js the name of the collection we
just created
add and then we put in a valid json
document yes it has to be val json or
the server will reject it
does some
checking there to make sure you're doing
the right thing and once the data is
there
we can do db
open js dot find this tells us all the
records i want to skip over the
underscore id
for this talk it has some important
information in there
but it's
primarily to be a primary key in the
database as you know our primary storage
engine is something called nodb which
would love for you to have primary keys
on everything
it sorts everything into a b tree and
this is the way we do it but you can
ignore it for now by the way if you want
to specify your own value for underscore
id you can do that too
now
uh
i think i showed this a little bit
earlier um
you can have your own script so if you
have a library that you like or a script
that you've written
that does certain things for you with
your data uh very easy to include it
and
in this case we're logged in
and create a variable called dave that
requires the dave.js file
and
if i just type d-a-v-e period and then
hit tab will show me my options are
hello and mysql as you can see
hello and mysql
and if i type dave.hello it prints out
hello there like you'd expect and the
same thing for dave.mysql
so it's very easy that if you have
libraries for statistics analytics
machine learning or whatever
very easy to include them with your
mysql shell
now the neat thing is the shell is
extensible you can define
what you want to do besides the base
functionality of the shell
and
write it yourself
in either javascript or python
and if you want to share this with other
people you can uh you don't have to
and this is a very
precise way of tuning the shell to
exactly what you need
now
you can persist these reports and
objects in what we call a plug-in that
are loaded automatically when your shell
starts
now to register a report it's very
simple
you
you write your code
in either javascript or python
and
the reporting facility handles built-in
reports very easily it's using the same
api for both languages
there's column a little differently i'll
point that out a little bit later
now reports can specify a list of report
specific options so like you want to
minus v for vervos or
something similar that
you can define all those you want and
have that work
and
you can also have reports that don't
need any uh qualifiers on the command
line
and
you can also put in a
help statement in there the new mysql
show one of these great features
besides command completion is the help
facility it really lets you drill down
and if you forget syntax on something uh
you can hit tab and it will prompt you
for the the closest available options
now registering shell reports is very
easy you'll notice the difference is
that when you register a report for
javascript it's register uppercase r
report
now in python it's all lowercase with a
underscore between them so if you write
something in python that you want to
call from
from javascript you'll probably follow
the same rules
so
here's an example in python
we're
we're defining a function called session
and this session we go out to the
schema which is our schema that has
metadata about your server
and we're going out there and from a
table instead of a json document
collection
we're going out and getting these
columns
and
doing some processing with them
and then we return a report
now we have
this function here shell.register report
we say okay we're going to have a report
called sessions
it's going to output a list
and this is the pointer to the function
up here
and this is the help information out
here with the brief and the details
and when you run that
it's rather exciting you can use
backslash watch sessions which is the
name of our function here in this case
we're running it every two seconds
so if you want to watch
something run
some command that you have
it's very handy to do that
now there are some built-in
functions already within mysql shell
there's watch query this is an interval
very half section second where we're
going to show global status like comm
wild card
other thing you do is show threads
which will go out there and check what's
going on
in your system
and this is the example slightly
different this is for a particular id
this is in the python mode not any
difference right there
now the mysql shell comes with a lot of
utilities built in and believe it or not
you can actually extend these if you
want to
the first one you'll probably run into
if you're running mysql57
is usual check for server upgrade this
will go out there and take a look at
your 5.7 instance and see if there's
anything
that you need to change before you
upgrade to version eight very very handy
highly recommended
if you're doing things like forcing the
use of the old temporary storage engine
we have a new temporary engine that's
much much much faster
if you're using something that wasn't a
reserved word but is now reserved word
it's there
i will worry about uh problems with
character sets and collations because in
mysql 8 by default everything is utf-8
and b4 you might be using something else
there's a whole bunch of other little
checks out there that are run for you
very very handy
another nice
utility we have out there
allows you to import json documents is
import json
and
in this case you tell it where the file
is
and then the schema you want to put it
in and what document collection you want
to drop in that information
and it will pull in all that data for
you
by the way it knows how to handle bsons
if you're coming from a [ __ ] background
uh you can either
ignore or inculcate that into your your
data
also there's a very nice
import table function
and
called import table creatively enough
and once again you tell it where the
file is
the schema you want to put that stuff in
there
the table that you're putting in there
now this is uh not important json it's
actually importing a a table
uh the dialect uh there are actually
several dialects of comma separated
variables uh
dos is one
uh you can skip over the first row if
that's all headers and i'll actually
draw you a progress chart so progress so
if you
want to run something and keep an eye on
it it's loading this huge file you can
actually get that little bar that draws
across your screen
we also have some other uh interesting
utilities
uh first i want to mention is the
parallel table import utility
uh this works in parallel i believe up
to eight threads uh this example once
again we give the name of the file the
schema or database we're putting in
there the name of the table
the dialect and show progress
and
what's fun to use that with is the
export table utility so this will export
in parallel and then you can read it in
in parallel
things like mysql dump are single
threaded so if you've been doing backups
with those
you're gonna love this
now even better than those and these are
less than uh six months old i believe
are the next couple utilities i'm going
to
to show you here
dump instance which takes the entire
server that you have there and we'll
write it out there
now in this example we're just doing a
dry run for timings to see how it works
and if you're on the oracle cloud
there's some id information stuff that
will do for you that's very handy
now here's an example we're going to use
the dump tables
utility
in this case we're going out to the
schema called hr
and in that we're going to take the
tables employees and salary
and we're going to throw that in an
object called emp
now if you don't want if you want to do
better than tables
there's dump schemas
where you can actually name the various
schemas that you're going to put out
there so you have instance for
everything schemas for specific
databases
in this example we're going to have one
called world
and
if you're using the mysql cloud again
there's buckets that you can set up
and compat building modes compatibility
modes that you can put out there
and also once you do a dump from either
dump instance or done schema you can use
load dump
and what you do is you tell it where the
data has been dumped to loads it back in
there very very fast if you've been
doing your backups with mysql dump you
might want to take a look at this
so
where do you go if you want to learn
more about extending the mysql shell
well the first thing i recommend is the
mysql shell manual itself
this is grown from
a fairly simple booklet to a commanding
tome all of its own
it has a lot of great examples and
explains things in great detail very
easily
well written easy to read
now if you're looking for a
quick howard who i write a plugin uh the
second
uh thing from
developper.com i thought it was very
well
now if you're looking for example
plugins my counterpart from
mia les fred
has a whole bunch of wonderful examples
out there they're mostly in python
but they'll give you the idea of what's
going on there
and
if you go out to slideshare.net this is
his presentation and from there he'll
have a link to his github account
and from there you can actually download
i think it's like a dozen or
dozen and a half wonderful examples of
how to
do various things
of various complexity from fairly simple
to very very very complex with the mysql
shell
and fred believes that the best tool for
a dba
to admin a server is the mysql shell i
haven't gone into some of the tools on
that for
setting up clusters
and cloning servers and all that but it
has a lot of other uses
and with that let me earn my pay by
saying if you want to test drive the
mysql database service which we call mds
for free you can get 300 in credits
and if you stay on the lower end
platforms that will last you quite a
long time
this is the full enterprise version of
mysql by the way
very very good deal there i encourage
you to try that
also please follow us on social media
we're at myschool.com
on twitter we're mysql facebook or mysql
linkedin.com we have over 20 000 people
as part of our
our last year group and of course mysql
community dot slash you're now part of
the moscow community please join us
there
and by the way if you are in a startup
oracle would like to help you out
they offer or we offer great discounts
uh global exposure marketing help
promotions
and access to oracle's over 400 000
customers
if you are a startup i highly recommend
recommend going to oracle.com startup
and signing up i am one of the startup
ambassadors if you have more questions
about that please contact me
by the way if you're interested in the
json data type and mysql
i've written a book now in second
editions called mysql and json a
practical programming guide
the manual is wonderful for the
json functions and json data type i just
wanted something something
wanted to write something more cohesive
and easier to follow uh reference
manuals are for reference they're not
for learning and this is a book designed
to teach you
how to exploit the json data type
and the surrounding the
facilities that mysql gives you with the
mysql server
to your advantage as quickly as easy as
possible
and with that
uh it's on the q a
hopefully uh during this presentation
which is pre-recorded i've been
answering your questions but if you have
been waiting to answer ask me a question
this is your time
and once again this go out to slideshare
dave stokes
you will find
the link to these slides look for openjs
2021 mysql shell and you should be right
to it
and
please ask me any questions you have now
if you're shy
there's my email and if you're semi-shy
there's my twitter handle and with that
i would like to thank you for
joining me today and thank you for
participating in openjs2021